[Musique]
je savais depuis longtemps qu'il y avait
un petit complot très très haut placés
dans ça faisait partie des armes donc je
sais ça depuis plusieurs mois donc je ne
suis pas étonné du tout
13% des gels hydro alcooliques qui sont
vendus sont non conformes et dangereux
c'est notre chiffre du jour là l'air
bien de la répression des fraudes qui a
mené l enquête propre l'autre et au
médical ou politiques betico politique
ça remonte jusqu'au ministre de la santé
je vous en dirais vous ne tirez pas et
vers du nez bienvenue chez pas ce genre
là parce qu'on sera passer à une
deuxième phase
parce que les indicateurs épidémique se
seront améliorées
on pourra effectivement envisagé de
rouvrir les commerces qui ne sommes pas
de première nécessité c'est pas normal
qu'on soit obligés d'attendre la de
l'émission d'après pour savoir comment
ça va se passer c'est ce qui manque
finalement c'est un peu le récit manger
d'exemple que chez coc ce couple que
c'est le le ministère qui dit la science
la science est pas le ministère qu'il
dit personne ne peut me dire la science
à moi il peut y avoir et c'est ce qui
est discuté en ce moment réfléchi
travaillé qu'ils pourraient être
annoncés le cas échéant une adaptation
du confinement à partir du 1er décembre
des joueurs qui l'entourent
mais il ne faudrait pas qu'elle laisse à
penser comme pourrait baisser en quoi
que ce soit la garde et nous ne sommes
pas du tout aidé confinement on est même
loin on parle d'une adaptation
éventuelle du confinement à partir du
1er décembre pour l'instant y'a pas de
vaccination contre le colis de 19
on verra bien si c'est un vaccin est
inquiet sur mon dieu pourquoi pas si
vous voulez mais pour l'instant la
question se pose pas tout ça c'est de la
science fiction
cette génération qui aujourd'hui se sent
sacrifiée et a le sentiment de payer un
prix très lourd
c'est cette génération qui va être aux
premières loges pour construire quelque
chose de différent dans notre pays qui
croit profondément
les actions de la bourse monde comme des
fous celui qui celui qui va gagner le
plus d'argent c'est celui qui en a gagné
d'ailleurs le plus jusqu'à maintenant
c'est pile grec moderne
voyez et donc je suis un peu sceptique
je me demande si c'est encore un jeu de
bitcoin je comprends surtout la colère
en fait qui s'exprime dans le pays un
sentiment que ya pas de pilote dans
l'avion parce que les mesures sont
prises quinqua la restauration c'est un
million d'emplois et autorise ces trois
millions d'emplois
regardez tout ce qui est à l'arrêt tout
ça ça fait 4000 emplois l'admettons en
seulement 50 % disparaît c'est deux
millions d'emplois le malin ce qui se
passe en 2021 est en effet en effet la
france est une cocotte minute dans la
parole d'un gamin ça c'est la police et
non un tribunal
nous le savons mais là alors nous avons
besoin de ces vidéos
elles sont essentielles pour la
démocratie dans ce qui concerne
l'article 24
je m'étonne un peu parce
qu'effectivement l'article me paraît
difficilement applicable ce texte pour
nous portent atteinte à des droits
fondamentaux de la république des
députés ont entamé l'examen du projet de
loi de sécurité globale qui encadre
strictement la diffusion des images des
policiers des gendarmes notamment et il
ya eu des incidents pris des incidents
en marge de ces manifestations
organisées autour de l'assemblée
nationale laliberté recul dans notre
pays tout le monde pourra y filmer tout
le temps partout sauf les policiers est
ce que les journalistes pourront
continuer à filmer la réponse est oui
pour aussi continuer à diffuser la
réponse est oui
est ce qu'un citoyen pour un film et
l'intervention de police la réponse est
oui
pourra t-il dénoncé au procureur la
république la réponse est oui
penguin ya pas dispositions pénales
c'est pas la loi qui va évidemment
protéger les français les forces de
l'ordre sont régulièrement attaqués on
l'a vu encore lié avec les manifestation
aux abords de l'assemblée nationale et
surtout certaines mesures comme la
protection des forces de l'ordre vont
dans le bon sens et nous les
approuveront